Wait!
Hmm?
Baa ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba This
sound weird!
What's going on?
Oh, it sounds normal.
I think.
Oh, hello welcome to the street.
welcome welcome there's a ghost in my room don't call an
exorcist hey that's against the rules actually you're not
allowed to call you're not allowed to say any exorcism
spells or call an exorcist or exercise the ghost so ban him
ban him ban him just kidding
always press the button oh i forgot to write i want to write
Let's see, one second.
Time of button pressed.
Let's see.
Let's have this up right up top right there.
Nice.
The button has been pressed zero times.
No exercise, chubby mint.
No!
I exercise.
What are you talking about?
Get a functional rex, but snake comes to destroy.
Sounds awesome, actually, if snake shows up at all.
Win for me, baby.
If we can't exercise, the ghost can the ghost at least
exercise.
Chubby mint you say.
Shut up.
All you degenerates, right now.
We're going to the Chubby Maid Cafe.
Stop it!
Hush, hush, hush, hush.
You guys are unbelievable.
You hear the C word and you're just like, Chubby?
Chubby?
Stummy?
Thighs?
Big, big, big boobs?
That's how really I know where I was going.
Neuron activated.
Anyway, what did I walk into?
Don't worry, please, man, I just woke up.
Good morning!
I don't even know.
I'm still tired, too.
I woke up and immediately...
Immediately, Matara and I recorded.
So I'm quite sleeping myself, actually.
And I have some stuff I need to do today.
So sorry.
So I have an early stream today.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Kelly, welcome back.
Name sword, welcome back.
Gerard, welcome back.
Zemplex, welcome back.
Amy, welcome back.
Thank you, guys.
Eepy, eepy.
I know, I'm so eepy lately.
Recently, I got a...
My cats like to wake me up very early to eat.
I recently got a food bowl that will like open up at 2 a.m.
So that they will stop waking me up.
Because my one cat like scratches the door and it's just the
most annoying thing ever.
Textarian, welcome back.
Jeremy, welcome back.
I've also pressed a button.
Derp, so welcome back.
Adashi, welcome back.
Today we're pressing buttons.
You guys push my buttons.
Okay, so this is a game.
It is a moral dilemma.
It is life or death.
Or in my case, death or death.
Where with, you give up, you are given something good, but
it comes at a price.
The monkey paw curls.
And so, despite that, that little, that little finger, will
you still push the button will you be approaching these
questions as made mint with made mint brain or as made mint
with a 12 year old gamer lad
brain I think today we can have a we can have a theme I
would like to maybe every We can only push the button if
it...
If, uh...
Hmm, what should the condition be?
We can only push the button...
If...
Press em the button...
Button em...
I don't know.
We'll come up with it as it goes.
Sorry.
My brain is not working today.
Press it for Hanya.
so let's start with our first one because this one seems
pretty whatever I opened a website and this is what it said
well you press the button you master every co-op multiplayer
local game ever made that's like a lot of games is this the
button am I pushing it wrong button ni hongo mo push the red
button shiny and red.
I agree.
But every word you type ends with an...
Mmm.
Um.
So, what is the...
What's bad about that?
Is it just annoying?
Every word?
So, it's like...
It's like that SpongeBob episode.
Is that... Wait, hold on.
I have to lean in.
Hold on.
Is that M or RN?
It's RN I thought it was an M Oh my god
I thought it was an M Oh my god Saku Thank you for the Aqua
Supra I got my bonus today So it is time to spoil the minto
for all the fun times so far Stop Play a straight poopy paws
and Butaro Why do you write Butaro like that?
Extra pets.
It's boo, like, boo.
Minto needs glasses?
Oh, I have my old contacts in today.
Also, wasn't there an Akasupa?
Go, sure.
Your Akasupa before stream, I saw it.
I saw it, thank you.
So it's like, okay, so it's like that SpongeBob episode
where it's like, I don't understand what you're saying.
Like that, right?
I don't understand but instead it's
Babycore things are the five gifted except but like what's
what's so bad about this I would be amazing at games people
would just think I'm annoying what's what's any different
than now I would be the best there is to ever be but it's
like also it's you master every co-op multiplayer game ever
made.
Like, that's also, that's also, like, why don't you just say
every game?
Why don't you just say every game ever made?
But also, I don't know, part of me is like, part of me is
like, then you have no challenge to get better at games.
It's games made today, not games made in the future.
No one says ever.
Oh, wait.
Ever made ever?
Ever made from win.
No?
Yeah, learning is fun.
But the money.
What?
Because I would be like a pro gamer?
People would definitely think I was cheating.
Tis himself.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
I guess not single player games.
Oh.
Oh, that's what they mean by local games then.
Ah, oh my god, I would be God at Mario Party.
I would be God at Mario Kart.
Local includes single probably.
That's what I was thinking, though, with the local.
But I guess if it means, like, local multiplayer, I don't
know, actually.
It would be an apex legend.
an Apex Legend.
I'm already an Apex Legend.
I don't know if you guys know that or anything.
You could speedrun Metal Gear.
I don't think I could ever speedrun Metal Gear.
Because...
The only way I would speedrun Metal Gear is if I...
Is if I am given...
If I can watch the cutscenes.
Because I cannot...
I physically cannot skip cutscenes.
I just love watching them so much.
Minto new Apex legend confirmed Yeah Dumb Got this stream
before my bedtime Good night, Chalice Thank you for always
writing my day I've been a silent viewer for a long while
And wanted to finally say Thanks for all the laughs and good
times Thank you I really appreciate it Thank you, thank you,
thank you
New category, cut 10%.
Sure, Jane.
It's Jan!
If you're gonna quote the line, get the name right!
It's not Jane, it was sure, Jan.
Oh my god!
I've never seen anyone stream MGS4.
Not yet.
Just wait.
until I get back when we start our Metal Gear Solid journey.
Oh, oh, oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Stop reading my typos.
Can't wait for the MGS4 watch along.
Yippee!
No one can spell today.
Is the MGS4 locked behind the PS4?
Uh, no, PS3.
I have my PS3 for it.
Yes.
I have it.
I have it all set up.
I could play it right now if I would...
Actually, no.
Because I would have to set up.
I would have to set up everything.
But I could do it today if I even wanted to.
I could.
But then I would cry.
Because it's MGS4.
Anyway.
You know what?
I don't care.
I'm gonna assume that local games is like local, you know,
like, it's multiplayer, but it's not online multiplayer.
I'm not gonna assume that it's, that it's single player
games.
I'm going to push the button, because who cares if everybody
just hears me go,
Every word ends with, so it's like, hey, you, um, you, um,
Get goodem, wait, getem, getem, getem, addem, the, giveem,
oh, it's our end, shoot, it's our end, hold on, uh, uh,
getem, getern, goodern, addern, learn, gamer, oh my gosh, it
would piss people off even more, oh my god, it would make
people so angry, Because they would be bad and then they
would also see me typing so annoyingly.
Oh my god.
GERM, GERM, GERM, GERM, GERM.
Cominta!
Vashami!
What?
Is it...
Is it too...
Is it still?
Still?
No.
Oh my gosh, it would be just like a plane.
Time to change all your passwords.
Oh my gosh, that would be so bad.
If my password leaked, you would know exactly what the last
two letters of my password will be.
Hurner, metal, metaler, gearer.
Gator, non-earn, my-earn.
It feels like I'm reading Lulite's speak or something.
It's so bad.
Oh, how mean to home.
Hello, Maya.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
But also.
You guys, I would have to make every tweet a voice tweet.
Because nobody would want to read my tweets anymore.
Because every word that I would type would end in R.
And oh, my gosh.
wait does this include like business emails and stuff okay
they would just think i'm really into the character you know
they'd be like nobody would want to nobody it's career
suicide but it doesn't matter all i have to do is speak it's
only typing press the button oh oh wait hold on i have a
button thing there we go 50 50 50 50 would would press the
button that's so crazy 50 50
what would you guys do would you press it would press the
button you can do voice to text for text for a loophole so
true So true!
I would not.
What's wrong with you guys?
Let's try the next one.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
wait.
Um, um, um.
How is this an issue for me?
Also, if there are only gay girls on the earth, that would
include everybody, though, right?
If it's only...
Then everybody is a gay girl.
Everybody is girl.
Right?
Yeah, it includes you.
It includes you, the viewer.
I'm pressing to see under girls' dresses.
Hallelujah.
What?
Why did you not press the button?
It's a win-win.
everybody girls girls rule the world
let's see will you press the button you get a million
dollars but you have to spend one night 9 p.m to 6 a.m in a
sentient walmart that's trying to kill you the entire time
you can't bring in weapons but you can use any weapons or
objects you find in the store well luckily it's a walmart so
um there's already guns in the
what are you talking about it's not even 20 minutes what do
you mean what do you mean
for a million dollars though for a million dollars hmm and
what 9 p.m to 6 a.m how long is that 9 to 10 10 11 12 wait 9
10 10 11 11 12 12 to 1, 1 to 2, 1, 2 to 3, 3 to 4, 4 to 5, 5
to 6.
9 hours?
9 hours for a million dollars?
I mean, a million...
Undaxed, right?
A million dollars doesn't really get you that...
I mean, it's a lot, don't get me wrong, but like...
Hmm.
It's not like what it used to be, you know?
It's not like what it used to be.
Oh, I didn't update the button counter, you're right, thank
you.
I've pressed the button two times already.
Dang.
Oh, nope.
You'd still have to pay taxes on this?
And it's like risking my life.
What's the most dangerous thing in Walmart?
Walmart?
I absolutely would, no question.
But best case, get eaten by a sentient Walmart.
Worst case, I get a million dollars.
It says it's trying to kill you, but they didn't say.
They didn't say how you would die.
Because what if it is, I mean, if it's like...
Oh my gosh, wait.
What if the Walmart is like a monster girl?
Oh my god, wait.
Can I Riz the Walmart?
Wait.
If it's like a, you know, it's like a...
It's like a monster girl who's like trying to, trying to,
you know, wait, actually cooking.
Romance route?
Yeah, let her cook, yeah.
Like monster house?
Oh my god.
Like, you've seen those, like, where there's like, it's
like, it looks like, you know, something unassuming, but
it's actually a monster girl.
You're awesome.
Thanks for the super time.
Thank you for the don't know.
As a Canadian, I wouldn't have to pay taxes on the million,
but also as a Canadian, there would be no guns in the
Walmart.
True, true, true.
It's a girl house.
Hmm.
I mean, sentient Walmart.
And also, like, how is it trying to kill me?
Like, what's it doing?
Like, what?
If I try to step outside, it closes the door on my foot?
Like, it doesn't really make much sense, I feel.
Like, it feels kind of like...
What?
Do they control everything inside the Walmart?
How can a Walmart kill you if you're already dead?
We're under the assumption that I'm alive, okay?
Which is really weird to think about, but...
Walmart's is dress.
Oh, I'm just kidding.
Raiders.
Oh, I don't see.
I don't see.
Who raided me, but thank you.
I think my pinned comment is blocking.
Sorry.
Yabe, I'm taking off your pinned comment.
I really liked it, though.
Robo, thanks for the vibe gifted.
Okay.
I think this one is kind of well okay what if it's not a
monster girl I will not push the button I think this one's
kind of whatever
54% did not I am of the majority I am of the majority he he
be me wow thank you thank you thank you
Andre goes thanks for the 10 gifted Let's see Alright let's
try the next one You can create anything you think of in a
matter of seconds It will be destroyed within 10 minutes
Okay this one seems way better than it seems worse Okay hold
on Hold on hold on hold on hold on Hold on hold on hold on
Everybody's saying why not Everybody's saying press Hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on you create
your dream girl you create a cat girl you're just like i can
create anything i create anime girl in real life you fall in
love you fall in love and then they're destroyed in 10
minutes no doubt just create her every 10 minutes you have
to oh my gosh what What if they, like, what if it says
destroyed?
That implies, like, she'll be in pain.
She'll be, like, destroyed, you know, in, like, a...
In, like, a painful, awful, terrible way.
She'll feel it every time.
Congratulations on your newborn son.
I created a son?
I...
Giving her the ReZero experience.
You guys have a lot of opinions on this one.
Holy cow.
It's useful though.
I'd say it's more useful.
Think of food.
Eat food.
Foods goes away after you're done.
No getting fat.
So if I just think of food.
Create con ticket, airplane ticket, money, etc.
So you use the money.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, you use the money.
money you use the money and then you then you then you pay
for the thing and then it disappears it's it's oh my gosh
it's foolproof it's robbery it's highway robbery
in a world where there is a ghost maid that is minty with a
weird obsession of metal gear
thanks she's called mid mid chat Kimani, we'll come back,
thank you.
Create a cold fusion reactor, study the design file patent.
And what is a cold fusion reactor?
No, I'm scared.
What are you trying to create?
You can also create a disappearing murder weapon.
You know, I thought of that also, too.
This is like the perfect way to commit a crime.
It does, it definitely...
This definitely feels like it has more uses than not uses,
right?
But also, isn't it that...
Oh, it's infinite energy.
Oh, but isn't it energy can't be created or destroyed?
So if you create something, and it's destroyed within 10
minutes, where is it going?
Hmm?
It's just gone.
Magic.
Black hole.
What if it's making the black hole bigger?
I use this power to create this Supai will disappear in 10
minutes, Mint.
Oh, I saw it, I saw it, I saw it!
I saw it!
You actually changed your name!
Create Oshi's open up meet and greet shop, Prophet.
Thank you, thank you!
Choo!
I'll call this wife of creation power.
51st creation states.
The circle of wife.
Okay, fine, we'll push the button.
Yeah, I figured most people would be pushing this.
We have pushed the button three times!
Okay, I'm gonna give myself a limit.
I'm gonna give myself a limit, you guys.
I can only push the button 10 times We are going to have to
be extremely Careful About what What we are pushing the
button for What happens if you exceed it Then you guys can
choose a punishment for me
We'll think of a Maybe I'll have to do a punishment stream
or a punishment tweet or something.
So, so, for these next ones, I've already pushed it three
times.
I've already pushed it.
I've been willy-nilly.
Okay, wait, two of them have been very good.
The seeing up this girl's skirts and seeing and pushing and
creating anything, I think both of those were good pushes.
I don't remember what the first one was.
for a comment section override.
What's that?
Oh, it was the R.
I'm off to a con now.
Have fun, everybody.
Remember, Minto is Quito.
Thank you, Latua.
Have a good time at your con.
Okay.
You can have, okay, Well, you press the button.
You can have any car you want for free and no problems
attached.
But every time you drive it for a total of one hour, your
life gets shorter by one year.
I don't care about cars.
Are you guys car people?
I think I know.
I think there's a few people maybe in the chat that are car
people.
But always be the passenger.
I'll hire a driver.
I like cars.
but no.
Like, I don't think I've ever had, like, a dream car or
anything like that, so create nanomachine.
Nanomachine creates more nanomachines.
Original nanomachines disappears.
New nanomachines make a new war.
Fist fight a cyborg on top of a giant robot.
Yeah!
Just sell it.
So it's every time I drive it, right?
So, I could yeah, I could generate any car that I want.
But what if I, like, generate it?
What if I have it?
Oh, wait, it's not generated.
People might be like, where'd you get that car?
I still don't think it's worth it, though.
I don't care about cars.
Cachow.
Selling for money, especially rare ones.
That sounds like such a pain in the butt, right?
What if, but then also, you know, You know, let's just,
let's, we don't know exactly how this works.
What if also the person driving it gets their life shorter
by one year?
Do I have to disclose that?
Then nobody will buy them, you know?
Oh, it's also, wait, it's just like you can have any car you
want for free, no problem.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, oh, boop, boop, no problem.
It says any car.
Is it unlimited?
Is it just one?
Oh, who knows?
I'll sell it to my enemy.
It says you.
Yeah, but...
I don't know.
What if I accidentally drive the car and I don't realize it?
What if the car somehow comes back to me?
And I accidentally drive it.
And I drive it for like...
10 hours.
That's a long time.
Drive!
Just how much tar I drive it.
Who do you think I was talking about when I saw my enemy?
Ronan, thank you!
What if I...
Can you drive?
I can!
I can drive!
So...
It's the plot of a Stephen King book?
No way!
I there's one what's it called there's one one there's only
one Stephen King book that I can think of that involves some
y 'all buy stuff in a car the lifespan shortening is a
pretty big problem for maybe a human but let's just assume
I'm human in some of these or in all of these you know let's
just assume I'm alive and I'm well and I'm healthy at a ripe
young age yeah
I don't think I will I don't like driving anyway but I don't
think I'm gonna press a button oh most people did not press
the button that's crazy
okay will you put oh come on come on these are so these are
so these are so pulling the world peace card is just It's
too easy.
It's too easy.
Come on.
Sci-fi.
World peace is achieved, but sci-fi, country, rock, and
metal music, video games, and books are abolished.
This is so stupid.
This is so dumb.
Who wrote this?
Like a 10-year-old wrote this.
Also, it's like sci-fi.
Wait, sci-fi is not a music genre.
This is so stupid.
I will not push the button because I don't want to give this
kid the satisfaction.
But also, it's just like...
I've watched Macross, and music will save the world.
I will not push the button!
Most people agree with me.
There are still sports.
Yeah, I skip out a protest.
Screw the world, I need my escapism.
Yeah, get out of here, world peace.
Video games, video games, video games, video games.
There's no video games, I'm basically out of a job.
The world can burn.
Burn.
Break stuff is a metal song, so we would miss you singing
that.
Yeah, without, yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Also, why did they include, like, these random assortments
of... Why didn't they just say music?
Why is it only country, rock, and metal music?
What about pop music?
What about...
I mean, that means, like, a lot of idols would still exist.
But what... Why... Yeah, no metal gear.
I would just... I would rather...
I would rather die again.
No, no, no.
Anime is still in, though.
Yeah, but you would have no anime openings.
An anime... You would have no anime openings and closing
songs.
Well, you would have only...
Yeah, if it's Annie's song, actually.
If it's Annie's song, what if it's a country Annie's?
What if it's a rock Annie song?
But it's classified under Annie's song.
I mean...
Hmm.
Found the loophole.
I'm still...
I can't get over sci-fi.
Country Annie's song.
Oh, yeah, there is Country Annie's song.
Country Roads!
This isn't a video game.
It's an interactive story.
No more Konosuba endings.
No more cyberpunk OST.
Is that sci-fi music?
It's a vicious cycle.
You get world peace, but you have people starting wars to
get back video games.
I need war so Metal Gear is created.
I'm just kidding.
Thank you for the super chat.
Okay, next.
Will you press the button?
You get paid $20 an hour to play video games.
The only games you can play are Mario Kart Wii, Farm Bill,
the first one, Sonic 06, and Candy Crush Saga.
$20 an hour to play video games.
Someone said, only 20!
What do you mean?
That's a lot.
That's a lot of money to play video games.
Okay.
Sonic 06's peak, press it.
Not gonna lie.
I was thinking about streaming it somewhat recently.
What is Farmville?
Farmville.
What is this?
Play Sonic 06.
I live this.
Don't take the deal.
I'm talking about Hayden.
It's $800 a month.
Oh, I would definitely need another job then.
Wait, what do you mean $800?
Wait.
No, it's $20 per hour.
It's $20 per hour.
So if I play Candy Crush for, like, forever, you know?
That would be, you know, it's per...
we're not who's to say that I have to stop at 40 who's to
say that I have to stop at 40 40 hours right who's to say
you'll want to stop what do you do in Farmville it's a
Facebook game series of agriculture simulation social
network games developed by Zynga in 2009.
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh my god.
I think my...
I think my cafe is haunted.
My lights just flickered.
I've seen VTubers play worse than this.
So you guys wouldn't hate if I became a...
Um...
A Farmville Mario Kart Wii...
Sonic 06 Candy Crush Saga streamer.
Can you zoom our max and have multiple Candy Crush gameplay
windows on stream and get paid more?
Hell yeah.
I'd be down.
I'm clearing my schedule.
I would judge you, but I would still watch.
Wait, if I was Mario Kart Wii, um, would you, would you
be...
Would you guys be able to play?
It would be sad there's no MGS.
Yeah, add metal gear in here.
No more metal gear.
No, I also wonder the only games you can play are these.
Are they the only games that I can play to get paid?
Or can I...
Can I...
Can I also...
Play things without getting paid?
I wonder.
Lupal!
Can only to get paid.
No, only those ever?
It doesn't say it's unclear.
It's unclear!
I'd assume only those games at all.
Then I will not push the button.
Wow!
That's actually pretty close.
But you know what?
I get it.
If it's $20, if you don't play video games very much and
it's just like, I don't care about video games.
And you're just like, I'm going to make $20 an hour, which
is good.
That's good to make good 20, right?
To make that.
I mean, I never made that much at a job.
So, yeah, to do that.
Not so much anymore.
Really?
Depends on where you live.
Hmm.
Well, to me, to me, it feels like a lot.
To me, it feels like a lot.
As a former game tester, it isn't worth it.
We have, we have the, we have the, the real testimonies of
Trevor.
Thank you, Trevor.
$20 is $20.
So true, thank you.
Thank you for the $20.
Let's see, what else?
What's the next one?
Okay, wait a second though.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Before we get ahead of ourselves, this game, this, this,
this site is making me, it's trying to turn me into a
pervert, I think.
Hold on, before we get too excited, before we get too
excited, you can see through all clothes.
One.
Can I turn this power off?
Two.
Can I decide whose clothes I want to see through?
You know?
I don't want to see through everybody's clothes.
Read the downside.
But you cannot turn the power off.
Okay, wait a second.
Wait a second.
Okay, I read the butt when I first pushed this, but I
thought it meant like the power, like electricity I thought
it meant like when you when you're trying to sleep the
lights are left on
Mean Green would be awkward.
No, you guys nobody would come to my Mean Green knowing that
I'm staring at them naked Or maybe you would you little
freaks Maybe you would you'd be like oh my god I'm into
seeing my naked body right now
Wouldn't you feel self-conscious, though?
I totally would.
They're little freaks.
But you can't turn the power off.
So I just see everybody's naked.
Eventually, at some point...
At some point...
Oh my gosh, no.
I will not push this.
Because...
Clothing is sexy, everybody, okay?
Clothing is sexy.
That would mean...
No more bunny girl outfits, no more maid outfits, no more,
no more swimsuits, nothing!
It would just be naked bodies everywhere!
There's, that's not sexy at all!
It would be so boring!
Then I would just be so sad, no cosplay ever, ever, ever!
I would be so sad!
Oh my God!
No!
I just, this sounds really, anybody who pushes this button
is so sad I think.
I think But Man It's actually a wholesome reason Is it Is it
wholesome for me to want to be like Um To be like Um What do
I To be obsessed with Cosplay Is that wholesome?
I'm not sure Ha ha ha But anyway, I will not be pushing the
button.
Okay, see, three out of ten times so far.
Oh, most people did not push the button.
Very good.
Also, there's a comment.
The first comment on here says, What if you can't find your
own clothes because you can't see them?
That's true.
Because other people wouldn't have the power.
And you can't find your own clothes.
your own clothes because because you can't see them and then
you could never go outside because what do you wait I guess
you would have to wrap yourself in a blanket all the time
blankets not clothes found the monkey paw I feel like I feel
like a kid wrote this question too next will you press the
button you can fly but you can't speak anymore and tweet
like a bird
So I'm like, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep,
weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, like that?
Or should it become a bird?
Sign language?
You can fly, but I...
Yeah, you could just learn sign language, right?
Or...
Or tweet, or it sound like a bird.
Talk with chat GPT.
Yeah, tech, you mean techs to speak?
Yeah, use a keyboard.
And then you can fly.
Flying is like the best power ever.
Right?
I can flow.
I can fly a little bit.
But not like, I can't, not so good.
You're already fly AF.
Oh my gosh, I'm Magic Do Do Do Johnson.
Thank you.
I'm like, she's so fly.
Chirp, chirp flies away.
Mmm, you can flow.
Yeah.
Flying is dangerous power, but can be fun.
Why do you think it's dangerous?
Speak vocaloid.
Because, like, teleport is better?
No!
I think, even still, I think I would rather fly than
teleport.
Depending on, like, how you're able to fly, right?
Because...
Because if it uses like a lot of energy, then of course,
then teleporting might be better.
But like, if you're flying, it's nice.
Unless it's raining or something.
I don't know.
If the weather's good, you're just like, wee, and you're in
the clouds, and it's nice and breezy, and you enjoy the
journey.
I guess it depends.
You enjoy the journey or not.
When I tweet, can I communicate with other birds?
This is important.
That's true.
Do I gain bird powers?
Can I control the pigeons?
Oh, I like mince boys.
Yeah, you lay eggs.
Wait.
Free food!
Wait, if I lay eggs and I eat them, is that eating my own
children?
Well, they're not fertilized eggs, so maybe it would be
okay.
I think Yeah, unfertilized, so no Yeah, yeah More like
eating your own placenta People do that, though They eat
their placenta once they have a baby I think Right?
That's the placenta, right?
Haruka, welcome back Doomguy
You're four to five, you're gifted.
I've heard of that.
Yeah, I've heard of that too.
Placenta hot dogs.
I'm gonna start selling my eggs.
Wait, not my eggs.
Wait, I don't...
Wait.
If I were to lay eggs, I would sell my eggs, but I would
cook them as hot dogs.
If Vint lays an egg, is it a ghost egg?
like a hollow plastic Easter egg.
Then...
But it would be kind of gooey, I think.
Hmm.
Egg glizzy.
Let's see.
The only thing...
Well, I guess, like you said, you can't speak anymore, but
that doesn't...
That won't...
Wait!
You can't speak anymore.
But that won't stop me from singing!
They didn't say I couldn't sing!
Yippee!
It's the loophole!
I'll take 10 hot dog eggs.
Hatsune Minto.
I am Burb.
We can...
We are quite communicative.
Also, you could write.
Yeah, exactly!
But all of this...
This is a lot to trade off for being able to fly.
Do you guys think being able to fly is worth it?
I think I kind of do.
I remember when I was a kid, I used to be able to wish I
could fly.
I used to be able to say, I used to say, I wish I could fly.
I used to say, I wish, well, I used to say, I wish I had a
cloud like Goku.
Guys, I only have 10.
the cafe.
You're so right.
We'd save on so much.
So many resources.
I've already pressed it three times.
If I press it one more, there'll be four.
That's how math works.
Okay, I'll press it.
Bing, Bing.
What?
Most people said no.
Oh, that's crazy.
Really?
Okay.
Such a bad deal, you think so?
I would say no to, but I want to fly.
Fine, then.
Let's go to the next one.
Okay, well, you press the button.
You have an internal tracking device inside your brain that
finds anything that you lose.
but everybody everyone knows of you having this power and
every day there are people asking you to find some of their
belongings basically the plot of the little mermaid for
landowners you're so right oh my god you're right wait so
you have an internal tracking device inside your brain that
finds anything that you you lose but everybody knows of you
having this power and There are people asking you to find
some of their own belongings.
So it's only...
It's not people.
You could charge people.
I could charge people.
Micmac, thanks to the five.
Gifted!
We could monetize this.
Yeah, this seems like a really good business opportunity.
Who is Yu Yu?
I don't know.
Maybe they meant Union.
From Konasuba.
But...
It's only belongings.
Um.
Huh.
Uh-oh, I feel like I should press the button again.
I feel like this is a good deal.
Hey, Mint, have you seen my phone?
Yeah, have you looked up your butt?
Wait, do you remember when kids used to say up your butt and
around the corner?
Oh my gosh, wait.
What if someone's like, hey, I haven't seen my mom?
And it's like, oh yeah, she's in my room.
Hey, y'all.
People stop saying that?
Do people still say that?
Anton, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Have you seen my wallet?
Yeah, have you checked?
Have you checked up your...
What do I just tell everybody?
their butt but it's only for what you lose not for what they
lose
i think it's just worded poorly because then why would
people be asking me about it
dragon thanks for the thank you don't do it i'll never end
honestly I don't lose that much stuff.
Actually, that's not true.
I lose my phone all the time.
I think I'm going to have to decline just because the
wording is kind of bad.
Forgot to join last month.
My bad homie.
No!
Thanks so much.
Okay.
Happens if crazy people threaten you.
I charge them more.
I say pay up.
Yep.
Alright, I'm just...
The wording's bad, so I will not.
Wow, most people pushed it.
Maybe because they also feel like they could monetize it.
Maybe they also are just like, yeah, I'll make a killing.
One, you're not forced to say yes.
Two, charge them if they want to.
Yeah.
Give them incorrect information.
But what if they come at me then?
What if they're just like, you were wrong?
I've been looking...
What if someone comes...
Oh my gosh, what if the government starts asking me where
they're like, where it is...
Oh my gosh, what if they're like, where is Amelia Earhart?
Where is Amelia Earhart's plane?
Where is...
Where is Cleopatra's tomb?
Sorry, those are on my brain because I was telling Matar
earlier about Cleopatra.
Where's my super suit?
Where is Metal Gear?
Oh my god.
Metal Gear?
Where is Garmin?
Where in the world is Garmin San Diego?
Duke, thanks for a month.
Okay, let's try the next one.
Will you press the button?
You would be the most popular person in town.
The only social network you could use...
Wait, you could use would be Google.
Plus?
I don't think you have...
Google Plus is not around anymore, right?
Yeah, Google Plus...
How old is this?
Google Plus is gone.
This one is old.
Ancient tech.
But like, you're the most popular person in town.
Also, like...
I don't...
Um...
You guys, I'm sorry, I'm going to be posting all of my
streams from now on from Google Plus.
Good luck, everybody.
B2, B5, oh, thanks for the
time.
Thank you so much.
You're already popular?
Stop it.
Google Plus ceased in 2019.
It was only 2019, it feels like it was so much older than
that.
Is it even still operational?
I don't think so.
Did you guys have Google Plus?
Did you guys have...
I think I tried using Google Plus.
I think because several idols that I liked started using it.
And I was like, fine, I'll use Google Plus.
Being popular is a curse, though.
I don't want to be...
I don't want people...
I don't think I want to be popular in the town.
I think I will not push the button.
I don't think I think I'm good.
I think I don't want to be the most popular person.
I think I'm okay
It can be back then used Google Plus.
Yeah, that's exactly what That's exactly why I used it
Because some of the some of the some of the AKB girls that I
liked were using it.
So Okay Didn't they force YouTube accounts into Google Plus
and change back?
I don't know.
Anything that Google is ever doing.
They confuse the heck out of me.
That's so weird.
Anyway, I will not be...
I don't care.
Yeah, most people...
Oh my gosh, there's comments on here from eight years ago.
This is so old.
This one comment, I hate attention, and I couldn't use
Tumblr?
Hell no.
Oh my god, I couldn't use Tumblr?
Oh no.
How else will I find out the ranking of the Tumblr sexy man?
Oh my gosh, I heard recently that Castio or Deistio.
DCL has been dethroned from Tumblr.
I've heard.
G Witch Sweep.
Yeah!
DCL was dethroned off of Tumblr by Suleimeo.
It's so crazy.
Which is the, which is, um, which is Saletta, Saletta and,
um, wait.
It's a, it's Gundam, Gundam Witch.
Witch for Mercury.
There we go.
It's them.
Isn't that, I was like, Gundam?
Gundam.
I know, I knew, I knew G-Witch was really popular, but I
didn't think it was so, so, so popular.
So, so popular.
Mmm.
I still need to get around to watching it.
I see.
Goodbye, DCO.
When you press the button, everyone works for you, but there
is always a rebellion.
Rebellion!
Wait, this is so funny because this is literally just...
This is literally just Chettino in Blue Archive.
Cheney No and Blue Archive, where everybody...
Blue Archive moment.
I know!
Hell yeah.
I pushed the button.
Rebellion!
Maybe I got a little too excited about that one.
I've already pushed the button five times.
But that's okay.
You have 10 million followers, but they're all on MySpace.
with oh gosh what was his name Mike who is the MySpace guy
the Patriots with Les Enfantelli be like Tom I'm friends
with Tom and that's all I need he's my friend oh he's my
friend if you want to be Chetino you have to put on a
mustache Do I even have a moustache?
Actually, I don't even know if I have one.
Hold on.
Oh, wait.
I think I must have one.
I must have one.
Oh.
I don't have one in...
In...
White, though.
Rebellion!
Oh.
Whispies of the world unite.
wouldn't rebel against me though the only thing we have to
lose are our aprons everyone works for you but there's
always a rebellion that's just chat you guys wouldn't rebel
against me you would be so happy
right every time i blink my mustache jumps
Vivala Rebellion!
Vic Boss!
That's what you should be saying instead.
Oh my god, it's the world peace question again!
The world will have no war, disease, destruction, and famine
for the rest of its days, but the USA will be wiped out from
existence by a nuclear apocalypse.
Will...
Meet again, don't know where, don't know when I know we'll
meet again some sunny day.
What was it, that was, um, what was it?
What was that movie?
Strange love!
I must ask you a question, but I shave it for later, mint.
Thank you.
I'm not taking questions at this time, thank you.
Whisper, whisper, whisper.
Dr. Strange, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like I hate world peace questions just because I feel
like it's a low blow.
You know?
I feel like it's not so interesting.
Let's just fall out.
I'm not wasting my press, you guys.
Yeah, they aren't fine.
I feel like they're just kind of like whatever.
It's like, world peace.
Or, it's like, world peace, but...
You lose fun!
Ha ha ha!
There's world peace!
Nobody would go against world peace!
That's what I feel like.
Everybody who creates these questions are just like, if you
go against world peace, you're terrible!
You're horrible!
Why would you deny world peace?
It's just like, because...
You know.
So it's lame So I do these out of protest Let's just ignore
it
World peace but you lose sci-fi
Will you press the button You get an alien where
But you can never download games Okay this is also The comet
on the top comet is eight years ago.
Okay, sundown right now.
Oh my god, this is so funny.
This is so...
Whoever created this was just like alienware is the tops.
The top of the top.
Did I tell you guys I got a new laptop?
I'm still setting it up.
But I got a new laptop.
It's a...
It's a Lenovo one.
World peace is real.
Peace day never came!
Is it alien wearing?
But yeah, I got a new one, so...
I will have it for streaming when I'm in Japan and stuff.
Lenovo's Sorry Yeah, it's the Lenovo Legion It's the Lenovo
Legion Yes, yes, yes, yes It's the Legion It's the Legion
Which I Was actually recommended before When I bought a
laptop previously And I went with the previous laptop And it
was so bad But I heard a lot of Good reviews about this one
So You get a Lenovo laptop But you can never download games
Yeah, hashtag but um yeah so the last two laptops have been
Lenovo I think honestly like honestly no matter what kind of
what kind of laptop or PC or well not PC I guess whatever
laptop you get there's always people always have issues some
issues with something so
let's hope it's good I hope so too so far it's been actually
so much better than my previous one so I am already I'm
already feeling good about it I'm already feeling better
about it I was watching I was thinking about getting the
what is it the ROG what was what's the not the not the
laptop oh wait blue archive the ROG Ally Yes, I was thinking
of getting one and then I saw a video on it recently and
actually one of the laptops I was looking at looking at too
was the ROG.
I'm kind of glad I didn't get it because um, oh some oh my
gosh
If you haven't seen the video I was like I was so shocked
you saw the video.
Yeah, I saw the video but I was thinking of getting the ROG
ally and then Um...
I didn't.
But also, a laptop I was looking at was ROG as well, so I
was like...
Touched a bullet, maybe.
Mmm.
Yeah.
But it was a while ago that I was thinking about it.
I got the... I got a Steam Deck instead.
I got a Steam Deck instead.
I could play Metal Gear on it.
This reminds me of another question.
Unlimited bacon and no video games?
for unlimited video games and no video games.
What kind of bacon?
Because I only like turkey bacon.
Did you get the OLED Steam Deck?
No.
I'm still rocking my original Switch.
Still got the old Steam Deck.
So, but maybe I'll upgrade after a while.
I don't know.
Legion is nice because they have tons of porridge.
It's so, it's also, It's not so heavy, and it's much bigger
than my last one.
So I think I'm going to be able to stream on it pretty
easily.
I'm really excited.
I was really excited getting it.
Might be a good idea to do a test stream before you leave if
you have time.
Last streamer I watched got a new laptop for a trip.
Ended suffering being bad than expected.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Maybe I will.
Okay, well, I'll do a test stream before.
It won't be like a real stream.
It'll be a test stream.
I'll do like a short test stream before I go.
Thanks for the idea!
Okay, anyway.
You guys, do I push the button on the alienware?
You guys, it's alienware laptop.
But I can never download games.
What's the point of getting a gaming laptop if you can never
download the games?
What else would you do with it?
browse Facebook.
Sorry, I'm thinking of eight years ago.
Okay, hold on, put your mind in eight years ago.
Which, put your mind in eight years ago.
Sell it.
Okay, so the way this is worded, it says you can never
download games.
Does that mean you can never download games again, or you
can never download games on the Alienware laptop?
These, the people that write these, they need to be more
specific because I have questions.
that, that, that must be answered.
It's too vague.
I think, I think we'll pass.
Everybody, everybody in consensus?
Oh my gosh, what is an alien?
You know, I, my first, you know when I first started
streaming?
When I first started streaming, it was, um, it was an alien.
Oh.
I spent a lot of money on my Alienware laptop, you guys.
When I first, back in 2020, I spent a lot of money on it.
You know what, this button is for me.
This question is for me.
Because was it worth it?
Well, I mean, actually, I still have the laptop.
It treated me well.
It was a little hard to stream.
No games, no way.
Did you make this question?
And you could still download games.
I could.
I downloaded them, yeah.
Lady Mint.
Integrated games are included.
And browser games are okay.
But what counts as an integrated game?
Mind Sweeper?
That explains so much.
Hey!
I...
I I How much did I make at my job?
I saved up a lot of money for my model And for my laptop I
made I think I made $13 an hour At my office job
I think I made $13 an hour And My model I remember I
remember I think I went with the lower pricing for my first
model I cannot remember how much it was I think rigging was
about 200 or 300 dollars and then with my laptop and I had
to get a mic and and the and the um I originally I I
originally used a mic on my headphones
this is pre-2018 so it makes sort of sense what the question
or me no this was in 2020 for me um
this was 2020 so um some people might remember the headset
mic I only used it for like like three streams or something.
But everybody complained about it so much.
I'm not complaining, but everybody commented about it so
much that I spent it then.
I then got a I then got a mic and a interface.
Toaster mic the OG?
Yeah!
It was a mic on a headset.
And then I still actually I still have the fan that
everybody helped fund me to get to.
The Dyson fan.
I still use it to this day so um all the way back i uh
people back then back then there were there were less of you
guys but but you guys helped me a lot by um by by helping me
be able to get the fan that i needed because i was stuck in
my closet and it was really really hot and i couldn't stream
for a long time because it would i would get like heat
stroke and um uh do you recommend the dyson fan i'm starting
to get hot here oh my god i've tried i have tried searching
for this fan i think they discontinued it it is these it is
such a good it is such a good fan it is small enough um for
it to like be on my desk and it keeps me so cool and it's so
quiet um and it was it was not so expensive it was like 200
i mean for a fan it's very expensive it was like 250
something dollars i think so um uh what's the model hold on
uh it's the dyson cool it doesn't have a model on it i'm
picking it up right now wait air multiplier technology
yeah and it's 250 for a fan well if you think about it like
I needed something really really quiet and yeah it's a
bladeless fan I needed something quiet I was worried about
something that would like you would hear too much on stream
and yeah it's one of the bladeless ones yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's so it's so great though it was so it's i i swear
like i'm so every time i use it i think of you guys i'm so
grateful for it because it's just so it's just so nice so
thank you i'm like hugging it right now oh my fan i love
your fan
and it like tilts it tilts and it has a little remote
control and it also like back and forth oh my gosh this was
like this was i think what am i this was like my first big
purchase as as a streamer so i was like i'm still it's like
my baby it's my it's my it's my favorite thing because i was
just like oh my gosh you guys work so hard to help me be
able to get the fan so i was like my it's like my you know
it's my it's my precious i think of it i I think of you guys
when I use it.
In fact, I'm going to turn it on right now.
Where's the remote?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, you hear that?
No, you don't.
Oh, my God, it's so cool.
I can't say I'm at work.
Just want to show support.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thanks for the super chat.
Thanks, Pepsi.
Good luck with the work.
Kind of like a trophy.
Yeah, exactly.
exactly exactly
how did you save up for all this stuff when the idols are
right there i um i i i you know you might think that i'm
like blowing my whole paycheck on idols but quite honestly
quite honestly my idols i can't buy so much from them mostly
just put out stuff when i when like it's in japan so if i
were in japan i would be like everything would go to them
probably hey you're a simp yes thank you in the past i used
to think that that comp the the your simp line was directed
at you guys like as a joke but now i think it's just fully
me i can't believe that mint is a favorite fan and it isn't
any of them What are you talking about?
Anyways, guys, I will be pushing the button for the alien
where left.
I'm kind of curious.
I want to kind of skew the ratio a little bit.
I want people to press this and be like, say, I will not.
What the hell?
Who would press the button on this?
And then realize how green.
Everybody, if you get this question on willyoupressthebutton
.com, push the button so we can skew it to 90%, okay?
What?
Wait.
That's so many more people!
Wait,
I thought it was gonna be like 2%.
What?
No way!
No way, that's insanity.
But also, the top comment says, You can never download
games.
Okay, I'll just get someone to do it for me.
LuPaul, LuPaul, LuPaul!
Loophole, loophole, loophole!
Wow, that's so funny.
Like, you guys, I'm getting an alien wear a laptop.
Whoop-ee-doo!
Let's see.
Alright, will you press the button?
You have your perfect body, but everyone thinks you're
hideous.
Um...
Oh my god.
The first, the comment on this is so sad.
The top comment or the top comment on this is so sad.
I pressed the button.
I am older and not attractive anymore anyways.
Nobody looks at me anymore.
And I am in poor health.
Having the perfect body would make me healthy again.
Plus I don't care what people think anyway.
What?
No, that's actually so sad.
wait that's i didn't wait wait that's actually so sad
oh my god i didn't expect to cry at the button no way to a
real comment man's going through it that's so sad oh my god
anyway um i have my perfect body what is my wait it says so
it's like in health or just like in in in physics physics is
it like would i have how big how big the how you know
actually i don't really want them too big you know flat is
justice after all wait how flat how flat can they be
Hmm, snake's physique.
Perfectly flat.
Concave?
I'm going to turn into like a black hole.
Yes.
medium is premium any prize i mean any size is a prize
everybody any size is a prize and you take that to the grave
you take that home any size is a prize amen can i get an
amen everyone will think you're hideous or everyone will
think you're hideous um i think i don't care um i don't care
I can see cute girl.
hmm.
Become a V-Tuber after.
I've become...
I've become so ugly, but...
I've become a V-Tuber.
That's why I'm a V-Tuber.
People who can show their face scary.
just be a vtuber but also I mean my perfect body I don't
feel like I I don't I mean not to say that I don't like I
don't really have a perfect body I don't even know what that
means I don't even know I heard every size is a fry I was
confused we should talk about some McDonald's cup sizes are
great letter grades a premium a premium beef a plus plus
what about S what if they start incorporating S into school
A5 they should they should I would S for sorry yeah S equals
100 yeah yeah yeah how big is a S boom
S boob size oh it's not showing me I'm seeing a G G G F oh
oh my god whoa whoa whoa it
says yours so it means what you want to look like my belief
is there is beauty and imperfection wow don't guy you're so
That's so philosophical.
Thanks, Doomguy.
Personally, I'll press.
I don't think I'm going to press because I don't really know
what a perfect body feels or like.
I don't know what I would want.
Could I be like a gelatinous mash?
Like a slime girl?
Would that count?
Could I be like a slime body?
Snake girl body?
I think people would think I'm hideous if I'm a snake girl.
If that's perfect to you Ectoplasm body I feel I become that
after stream I use up all my energy And I'm just like Turn
into Turn into slime You know
Okay I'm not gonna press a button And I'm a ghost I don't
really care.
Wow, most people did not press it.
72%.
Wow.
Next.
Anime!
Will you press the button?
You get to publish a manga or create an anime with whatever
storyline you want.
But the manga art is terrible or anime is in terrible
English dub.
Okay.
Um.
Yeah, but.
What about the Japanese dub?
What about the Japanese version?
Who's the seiyu?
Oh, no.
Wait, publish a manga or create an anime with whatever
storyline you want.
Whatever I want?
Google says, JP cup sizes go up to 2.5 centimeter per
letter.
So a 55S has a overbust of 105 to 107.5 centimeters.
centimeters 41.5 to 42.5 inches i've definitely seen that
size on my on on dvnard this is literally one punch man
you're a sim girl mint model funds oh thank you some
terrible english dubs are amazing yeah right
the top comment on this is i just don't like manga and anime
so i don't really care
oh no this is about anime oh my gosh what would we create
well recently i thought of a anime idea kind of i was like i
was like kind of cooking i was like I was on the train in
Japan and I was like looking out the window.
I was standing and like just watching things.
And I thought of like either a four coma type anime or like
a short, you know how some anime like have really short
episodes.
Something really short.
And I was like, what if there was like an anime?
It would be like kind of slice of life.
It would be really cute, kind of cozy like a Yudu camp.
But like when I was on the train, I was like looking out the
window and just kind of seeing little flashes of...
stuff that would be going on little like bits of life so
like it would be like we'd go by i don't know like a i don't
know like i would see i would see something like someone
walking their dog or something you know and in my brain i
was like creating a whole story about them i was just like
they're walking their dog and their dog runs away and bumps
into another guy walking their dog and then they fall in
love and it becomes and i was like what if there was like an
anime about a girl who was like looking out the window and
would see little blips of life and then she would also come
up with her own stories for like what people are like but
they'd be crazy you know so it's like just like 101
Dalmatians but yeah and it's like they have like uh she so
she sees like someone doing their laundry and she just comes
up with the whole like little storyline in her head about
like you know it's like what what is what is minto chan
looking outside the window and thinking of i don't know it
was it's a very loose idea that i think came up with like um
when i was in japan and i was thinking about it i was like i
was like what like how how would i be able to turn this into
an anime daydreamers delusions oh my gosh wait that sounds
like such a good title
Oh my god, that sounds so cute Pitch a tamapa No, no
So Yeah, sounds a little like Nietzsche Oh, I guess you're
right Yeah But it was like, it was like very short In my
brain because it's like You can't really turn a show And
then like maybe another person it enters the train and like
she also has her weird delusions we're all just all having
our delusions you know have ayami sensei draw the manga i
think it would end in my brain it's a little more say-so
than that i think with how ayami sensei would draw it it
would become
it would uh
That's the plot of Gekkan Shoujo Nozaki-kun.
Is it really?
I've never actually seen Nozaki-kun.
But mine all takes place within a train.
Anyway, what was it?
Oh, yeah.
Publish a manga or create an anime with whatever storyline
you want.
Storyline I want.
Um.
Me.
out with me.
I'm Mint Phantom.
And you might be wondering, how did I get into this
situation where, um, uh, there's girls.
There, I'm at a, I'm at a bathing suit wet t-shirt contest.
And, um, oh, fuck, push the button.
Okay.
Ah, you guys, I only have three more tries to push the
button.
They only have three more to push the button!
What's wrong?
Oh gosh.
It's okay.
The JP, the Japanese version, the English dub is fine.
I don't care if it's bad.
I just need the Japanese to be good.
And even if the manga art is bad, it's fine.
If it's a ghost story style dub, I will press the button in
a heartbeat.
So true.
Will you press the button?
You'll be able to create your own reality at any time.
But after 25 uses, you will be stuck in your own reality and
not be able to go back to the original world.
Ooh.
Easy press.
Press the button and call Kojima.
It's time for Metal Gear and the anime with the terrible
English stuff.
Oh my god, Kiefer Sutherland's back.
He's voicing all of Snake.
Oh no!
Not to say he was bad, but you know, not having David Hater
would probably make it bad, right?
I feel like there's no downside to this, right?
Be able to create your own reality at any time.
Like, what's the downside?
25 uses.
You just...
You just keep track, Bozo.
But also, you only need one use.
Yeah, I'm kind of confused.
What if you, like...
What if you...
Create...
If you create your own reality, you're controlling
everything in it.
Are you not?
Like, reality...
I...
If you're...
If you're creating your own reality that's...
Whatever you want...
then it's like
just use it 24 times and save the 25th to reset everything
if necessary yeah
oh my gosh you guys I'm only gonna have two more presses
okay here we go yeah I figured most people would press this
I figured most people would press this
yeah it makes sense yeah makes sense like how is it a choice
yeah you're right yeah well you press the button you are
never sick but you are always exhausted I might as well be
sick I might as well be sick right um what do you mean I'm
always exhausted no I will not press the button on that that
sounds crazy That's me now.
No.
I'm always exhausted anyways, Saj.
Well, then you could push it.
Because then, you know, different.
But there will be some day that you're not always exhausted.
But if you push the button, you'll always be exhausted.
You know?
There will be, there will come a time when you are not
exhausted.
You know?
And so you, that will be a time.
what happens and at that time you'll feel so much better and
you'll feel so good and feel so much relief next will you
press the button you can watch any book is a film in your
head but Kristen Stewart is the lead actor what's wrong with
that Kristen Stewart a solid snake you can watch any book as
a film in your head.
What?
Who?
Kristen Stewart?
She's the girl that played... I think... is this like around
Twilight era or something?
She's the girl that plays Bella Swan in Twilight.
This is such a 2012 thing.
It really is.
What's wrong with Kristen Stewart?
I see no downside, but I also see no upside.
I mean, Kristen Stewart's fine, but like, Shrek?
Oh, yeah.
Yes, my favorite novel, Shrek.
Oh yes.
I love reading the classics.
To kill a mocking bird.
The Great Gatsby.
Shrek.
Shrek is an old book actually.
Huh?
Shrek is based on a book?
Wait, really?
Shrek the novel.
Shrek!
With an exclamation point!
Oh!
Shrek is a fantasy comedy picture book published in 1990!
What the?!
The book served as the basis for the first Shrek film!
Oh!
What the?
It's a Shrek with an exclamation point!
But is it a... wait, is it a...
oh it's a it's a picture book though it's a picture book
everybody it's a picture book it's a picture i don't think
picture books count i don't think picture books count
because because i don't think picture books count because
they're pictures should only be books books books sammy
thanks for the one man thank you i'd do it to see her play
bilbo faggins
I says that it says any book That means manga doesn't count
Yeah, probably No, manga shouldn't count either I think it
should be only books books Not picture books Not comic books
Just book books Regular books
I cannot believe that there is a Shrek book What is going
on?
This isn't real Is this a real part of the book?
Hold on.
Wait, is this a real part of the book?
The picture looks legit, though.
I don't think this is real.
Shrek was still hungry, so he ate a bolt of lightning.
Yum, said Shrek.
My diet is everything.
You eat my food, said the cloud that made the lightning.
Okay, said Shrek, I will get your tip from my bag.
Shrek reached into his bag for his gun that killed clouds.
Yeah, I gotta read this book.
It's real.
Will you press the button?
You can eat lightning bolts, but you have to kill the
clouds.
lightning bolt.
I think I would.
I would, would, would.
Oh wait.
Wait, there's another one.
That's the same picture, but different... Okay, I think it's
edited.
What is... What?
Wait, is this the real thing?
Now I can't... Now I don't know.
Wait, now I don't know what's real!
This one.
Fat raindrops began sizzling on Shrek's hot knob.
Did you ever see something so disgusting, said lightning to
thunder?
Never, thunder growled.
Let's give him the works.
Lightning fired his fierce bolt straight at Shrek's head.
Shrek just gobbled it, belched some smoke, and grinned.
Lightning, thunder, and rain departed.
They just laughed.
Is this real?
His what?
What's a hot knob?
His head?
Is it those little...
The little bump?
I think it's the bump on his head, you guys.
That is the real book.
So would Christian be the Minotaur or the farmer?
No way.
I think...
it's the thing on the top of his head, right?
Is it the little lump on his head?
The actual book is more ridiculous than the edit.
Wait, what's...
Which is real?
Well, I don't think the first one is real.
Is this one?
This one seems more real.
The first one seems a little...
I don't think Shrek has a gun.
Oh, that's a stick.
That's not a gun.
Oh my gosh.
I thought it was a gun.
Okay.
Nicole!
Welcome to VemboShift.
Thank you!
I'm going to not press the button because I don't really
care about Kristen Stewart.
And also... I don't feel... I feel... I don't... I mean...
I don't see a very good side to this.
Most people didn't care.
Most people were like, whatever.
Who would play Mint Phantom?
Um...
Will you press the button?
You will have the force, but you will become a cat.
It's my dream.
It's my dream to become a cat.
I just want to be...
Jack Black!
Oh my gosh, I would love Jack Black to play me.
In the movie?
Jack Black!
Jack Black in the movie!
What's the downside?
Yeah, you become a cat!
I see no downside at all here.
I've always wanted to become a cat.
I always think, you know, if I ever can become reincarnated,
since I'm already dead, if I can never be born again, I want
to be a cat.
I want to be born as a cat.
I want to be born as a cat in a house where I'm just loved,
and I just get to lay around and do nothing all the time.
Cat that shoots lightning.
What is the force?
The force is like being able to move stuff with your brain,
right?
That's it?
Will you be a poopy cat?
Maybe.
It's a trick.
Cats already have the force.
Mint, I am your father, meow.
I kick telekinesis.
Telekinesis, mind control, lightning!
You guys, if I press this, I only have one more shot before
I can, before I'm out.
I only have one more button press.
I only have one more.
Also, as you can see, 328 comments.
People are very passionate about this one.
I only have one more.
Well, the force is an energy field around all of us.
Oh, okay.
Press it.
pressed it Wow alrighty what I will do is let's do 10 more
let's do 10 more and within that 10 I could only do one okay
so I'm gonna say left 10 I'm just gonna I'm gonna move it
over here so we have 10 more and then I can only push the
button on one of them.
You become a member of your favorite musical group!
But the person you end up replacing will completely cease...
No!
I would never.
Do not press.
The person who you end up replacing will completely cease to
exist.
Like...
If I become a member of my favorite musical group...
I wouldn't even be a man I wouldn't even be probably so much
of a fan if they didn't exist I will not press and I'm glad
most people have taste all right nine left okay guys next oh
uh
I will not press
too much text mucho texto next i'm not going to count that
one
uh you are amazing football player but you have to be half
human half eagle what in the my hero academia
this one has no downsides you are an amazing football player
but you have I'm bird person.
I think I'm already half eagle a little bit.
But the eagle flies higher above the clouds.
Press it.
No.
What are the upsides?
I'm half eagle.
What are you talking about?
I'm a harpy at that point.
I'm a harpy.
No, is this the American dream?
I think so.
I'm sure there might be some people, some EU watchers today
because my streams are a little bit early.
This is it.
This is the American dream!
Pay my monthly rent to the half eagle main.
Thank you.
Soaring puts.
Aren't you already a cat?
Imagine just flying over the competition going, your
flightless legs are useless against me.
Scaa!
The downside is now that you have to live in Philadelphia.
Oh, I still have my mustache on, I forgot.
Sorry.
Oh, the revolution is over.
Forget the age of 30, I hear monster girls are in demand.
I mean, I'm a ghost, so I'm technically a monster girl.
Right?
I think I'm technically a monster girl.
I'm in the Mario 7 and the Monster Girl Encyclopedia, so...
I mean...
You know, so...
And I hear ghosts are in demand.
What was this?
Oh.
I really want to become an eagle.
I want to become happy.
Eagle you guys anything from here on out if I push this
button anything else we're gonna have to not push the button
or else I'm gonna get punished
you can't touch a ghost 0 out of 10 monster GF okay hold on
hold on 0 out of 10 give me at least one point because I
could still possess you and also I mean, you can't really
touch me.
But I mean, there's also ectoplasm.
Don't think so hard about it, okay?
Take the punishment like a boss.
Push the button because eagles are free!
Sky!
Why did most people not push the button?
What the?
Most people did not push the button!
Why?
What's the downside?
You are conscious in your dreams, but you only have
nightmares.
Where is the good side?
Where is the good side of this one?
Cowards.
They were all cowards.
There is no good...
This one is actually so bad.
Why would I want to be conscious in my dreams if they're
just nightmares?
Yeah, why would that be good?
Maybe because then if I'm conscious, I could be like, oh,
this is just a nightmare.
This is just a, or rather, this is just a dream.
It's no big deal.
And then I won't be so scared of it, I'm guessing.
Is the thought process, no.
Get this out of here.
You will swap genders, but you will still have the same
personality and relative attractiveness as before.
So I'll be fucking ugly.
I will not push the button.
What?
Anyway.
This is only bad for me.
If I still have the same personality and everything, I'm
just going to be actually a terrible, ugly idol Oji-san.
And all my idols will hate me.
I can only be Oji-san because I'm a girl.
And so it's...
Oh, come on.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
Uh, what?
Left is 7.
Well, you press the button.
You can sleep with anyone you choose, but every other person
has to be someone you don't want to sleep with.
I like sleeping by myself, though.
It's too hot in the bed.
I will not be pushing the button.
What's the good side of this?
It's just disrupting my sleep schedule.
Wow, most people didn't press the button.
Next.
Six.
So, oh, not 56.
So far, these are not so bad.
Half-Life 3 will be released for free for everyone.
But you can never play.
Take one for the team.
Save the people, Mint.
That's a freebie.
No, no, no.
There are no freebies.
There are.
Remember that Henya once Half-Life 3?
But...
I'll be your hero.
Hold on.
I need some dramatic music.
What the hell?
Oh.
Why are all these playlists?
Hold on.
I don't know how dramatic this is, but I'm gonna play it.
I've never played Half-Life.
But.
For everybody's sake.
Who's been waiting for Half-Life 3.
All those years.
That you've been waiting.
Hoping.
Praying.
Wishing.
On a fallen star.
Someday please.
Half-Life 3 and I hope I hope it's a great one I hope I
hope it's the greatest disappointment of your life I hope
you waited 20 years 84 years for shit I hope it comes out
and I never play it I can never play it and I hope it's
Terrible for all you guys and it will be the worst.
Oh my god, and it's going to be awful It's going to be so
bad.
You're going to be so disappointed Yeah
Anyway, where were we?
Where were we?
Oh, yeah
Most people didn't press it.
I contributed to the green.
To lighten up this moment, has Mint heard the Burger King
rep commercial about SpongeBob Square Ass?
This is real.
I've never heard that.
Half-Life 3 is going to be a live service game.
Done,
done, done.
You can make anything taste like what you want it to, but
you will be constantly hungry.
Oh, no, no, no.
Constantly hungry, then what's the point of even eating what
I want?
What's the point?
Half-Life 3, but with Blue Archive characters?
Okay, do you want the greatest game ever?
Put Blue Archive characters in anything, and I'll be happy.
You should let Hania decide your punishment.
Okay.
I will not.
And most people agree with me.
Four.
What if you could stay alive forever, but you cannot
communicate with anyone but yourself?
Um, I, who?
Okay.
Alexa, play break so I've been fed them.
Um, this is like, wait, do people actually want to stay
alive forever?
Shinsular, thanks for the 10 gifts!
Do people actually want to stay alive forever?
Like, is that actually something?
Like, if people ever just think about it for just a tiny
moment, like like just a tiny moment and also think you
cannot communicate with anyone but yourself like it would be
so bad we get boring fast right this is like a huge
trade-off so no okay next
You get your own free private jet and a lifetime supply of
jet fuel, in-flight snacks, drinks, in-flight movies, and a
busty flight attendants!
But the busty flight attendants.
But the bust...
But your private jet will one day be used in a massive
terrorist attack.
You do not know which day that will be.
But then they'll die!
You guys, I can't because the busty flight attendants will
then cease to exist, I think.
I think they'll die on the plane.
That would be so sad.
That would be so sad for them.
And the world.
Being deprived of less buba.
Save them.
By not have...
By...
But also...
Also, what if we do invent, invent, um, oh wait, it says you
get your own free private jet and a lifetime supply of jet
fuel.
In-flight snacks.
Drinks in flight.
What do you mean snacks?
What are we talking about?
Like those tiny bags of pretzels that has two pretzels in
them?
I don't want snacks.
I want a whole ass meal.
Save the buba.
Save the busty.
This is literally.
This is, are you guys for, save the animals or kill the
animal?
That's a GDQ question.
Save the Busty Flight Attendance or kill the, hold on, let's
make a poll.
Let's make a poll.
Okay guys, save or kill.
Save the Busty Flight Attendance.
attendance start save the animals did it go oh there it is
oh wow a lot of people for saving them oh I spelled
attendance wrong it's okay save the Save the booba, save the
booba.
Save the BFA.
Hashtag save the BFA.
Save the frames.
Kill the animals, save the frames.
Hmm.
Most people are saying save the bus safe flight attendants.
Flying is miserable anyway.
I don't mind flying so much, I'll be honest.
Greetings from Germany.
First time watcher.
Long time chatter.
Save the attendance.
Thank you.
Implode.
Plot twist.
The attendants are the terrorists.
And what if my jet is actually Metal Gear?
What are their demands?
Big boss's body?
Or...
Even with that free, planes will bankrupt you.
That's true.
No more business class feet.
True.
No, it's getting interesting.
Hmm.
All right.
Most people say, save the BFA.
Goodbye, frame.
I will not be!
Wow, most people said no.
Most people also believe in the BFA.
Let's see next.
Everything you say will come true, but you will get the
opposite of what you say.
This is just like a monkey paw thing, isn't it?
What is the good side of this?
it.
Keep the BFA.
Then it's out of my hands.
I wash my hands of this.
What if one of the attendants is just Ocelot in a skirt and
an open blouse?
I don't think he is busty enough.
Is he busty enough?
I don't know.
Just say the opposite.
So say everything I say won't come true.
Wait.
Hold on.
Say.
I.
Everything I say.
Wait.
How do you, how do you phrase this?
Say all the negative.
Oh yeah.
Gosh.
I wish I won't.
have a busty flight attendants I don't want one million
dollars in my bank account but then what if you accidentally
say something say something that what if you accidentally
what if you accidentally mess it up this one is a scam I
feel like it's too easy to miss to slip up you know it's too
easy to slip up i think get rid of it after your best wishes
again right i will not be pressing the button okay guys wow
he only pressed it one over
um this one is also kind of wait you can become invisible
but it works only one minute every day what's the downside
what's the downside That it's a minute?
Who cares?
It's a free minute.
There's no downside.
Hold on.
You guys...
Let's skip this one.
It's just a net good.
Can I press it, but not count?
Actually, can I just skip it?
Yeah, there needs to be a downside for it.
But you're a ghost anyway.
Yeah, it doesn't really even pertain to me.
I'm in your rooms all the time.
Okay.
Skip, skip.
I'm the minority.
Okay.
You get 3,000 pounds or US $3,000 for Brits per day.
But you cannot exchange it for your local currency.
Um...
So I just moved to...
I just moved there?
Like...
What's the down?
I just get 3,000 pounds a day!
Living in England.
Just save up and move.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
to the uk but it's free money you can't exchange it for your
local currency so like what if i go on a trip i can exchange
it for that currency so i could exchange it for like
i could exchange it to another currency is fine
uh I'd rather die than become British.
This one is a great one to end on for our EU friends today.
For those watching in the EU hours.
This one maybe is a good one to end on.
Local means wherever you are.
So I'm just stuck in the UK.
I suppose.
Right.
But also, also, consider this, consider this.
If I buy something with a credit card, it doesn't matter
what the currency is, right?
It just uses it.
So, a simp.
It doesn't say you can't exchange it for yen and then buy
everything on AmiYami.
So, I don't know about exchanging things.
Well, oh, two yen is fine, yeah.
Right?
So, Bitcoin?
Oh, no, not the cryptocurrency loophole.
So yeah, if I just, if I just put it, if I just have it in
my bank account and use my credit card, it should be fine.
There's no negative.
Push that button!
Well, guys, oh, wait.
I think I...
There we go, zero.
Well, guys, I pushed it.
I went over the limit.
I will have a punishment.
I will accept my punishment.
Somehow.
We'll figure something out.
I missed one earlier.
Wait, I did.
Wait, the left or the...
Two punishments.
No!
The limit does not exist!
What have you been watching?
Mean Girls lately?
Your punishment is a speedrun.
MGS1, but you must skip all cutscenes.
That's just torture!
Matara gives one, Hena gives one.
and I will ask Matara for a punishment from each of them.
And I will do a punishment from each of them.
So once I know the punishment, here I'll even message them
right now.
I think Matara is streaming.
Oh my god.
This is so cute.
Maya, oh my gosh, if you're still here, I just saw your
message.
I just opened up.
Okay, Matara.
free i lost a batu or i i lost a challenge on my stream
today can you give me a batu to do sad face and henya where
is henya henya I was um I was playing a game on stream and I
lost so I have to do a punishment crying crying crying
crying crying crying crying my chat wants you to choose a
punishment for me
Whenever I receive these, I will do them, I suppose.
Can you give me a...
Okay, okay, okay.
And it was for Half-Life 3.
Hold on, sorry, I'm responding
to something.
I sent that exact emoji.
I sent that exact emote to Henya of me crying.
The same one.
Both of them.
And also the PN.
PN, PN, PN, PN, PN, PN, PN, PN, PN.
Hoki-doki, guys.
Wow.
We had some tough ones.
Some of them were really easy, but some of them were pretty
tough.
I'm glad that we are all in agreement that we would become
eagle people.
Eagle people rise!
Eagle people!
Roooo!
Anyway.
Thank you guys for the stream today.
This was very interesting.
Some of these prompts were crazy.
Thanks for all the button pushing.
Just curious if you saw the trailer for Beetlejuice 2.
I did!
Not sure if he's a ghost role model for you or not.
Oh my gosh, I did see the trailer.
I saw it last night.
Oh my gosh.
And how Winner-Writer's back.
And they like, it's all still so campy looking.
It looks so good.
I'm excited.
It looks kind of fun.
I probably will watch it.
But you have to play football.
Oh, but I'm an eagle.
I'm good at football.
It doesn't matter.
I could probably take them all down in one person.
One eagle.
Half person.
I could take them down.
Half person, half eagle.
Baloney, thanks for the 10 gifted.
No, I just got here, PN.
Sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm cautiously optimistic about the movie.
Looks like they're still using stop motion.
Yeah.
I know, it's really cool.
Hmm.
So.
I've never seen Beetlejuice, but the Broadway tour is going
to be here.
Should I go?
Oh!
I've seen some clips from the Broadway show.
It looks funny.
It looks interesting.
Why not?
If you guys say my name three times, I might appear.
But sometimes.
Sometimes it only feels like if I don't want to appear.
Sometimes I don't want to appear.
You know?
So it's like when you call to a cat.
You're just like.
Come on.
Come here, cat.
Sometimes they come, sometimes they don't.
It's the same with me.
You can try.
Try saying, mint phantom, mint phantom, mint phantom, and I
might appear.
Sometimes I won't.
I don't know.
It depends on how I feel.
You know?
So you can go ahead and try it.
I don't know.
Oh!
Ew!
Matara sent me one too.
Oh my god.
No!
Hanya sent me one.
She sent me the game of Sisyphus.
She wants me to play as a Sisyphus.
No!
And Matara sent me one.
She said kiss me on the mouth.
No.
Something else.
It's not that that bad though, is it?
It can't be that bad.
I saw Fauna cleared it, right?
Randall, thanks for the five gifting.
Thank you so much.
Can't be that bad, right?
Fauna just ran up the hill.
She cleared it without touching the boulder.
Oh my god, God Gamer.
God Gamer.
Well, um, then I, um, then I'll, uh, do, I'll, I'll play it,
I guess.
Wait, hold on.
Uh oh, my YouTube is frozen.
I'm just gonna look at chat from here.
I meant about that poll.
Don't worry about it.
Don't even worry about it.
If you say phantom three times fast, you get a big phantom
appreciate power time.
Ooh, wait, what?
Oh, no, wait, this doesn't work either.
I can't, I can't see you or I can't, I can't scroll up, so I
can't read it.
Hold on.
One second.
There we go.
You get big phantom appreciate power time when you're in the
gym.
Wow.
Phantom game gains.
Get the phantom gains, everybody.
You get phantom gains.
app time.
No!
Thank you guys for watching my stream.
Thank you.
I will see you guys tomorrow.
I will be not streaming.
I will be at Anime North in the parking lot, baby.
But thank you guys for helping me make these super duper
difficult decisions.
I guess I will play as a Sisyphus before before oh Matara
says
Matara is still coming up with the punishment and I will
play the Sisyphus sometime thank you guys thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you and
I'll see you later bye men bye back the bill thank you for a
month Bye bye, Otzumin to eat at Edouashai Have a good day,
have a good night Bye bye, bye, bye thank you, thank you,
thank you Woo,
Mario Kart Wii Woohoo, Mario Kart Wii
Actually, hold on, that's gonna be the ending music today
That's gonna be the ending music today It's not obvious,
totally You got the golden star!
Get coconut mold!
I don't remember the middle of the song!
You just got coconut mug.